the fed just flooded this system with
money right you mentioned it
unprecedented amounts of money people
were putting their stimulus checks into
bitcoin and naturally there was a bull
market going on you had the halving back
in 2020 naturally a bull market tends to
follow after that so with all that
surplus cash plus an impending bull
market naturally it's going to go up now
we're at a point where the fed is
starting to take you know inflation
seriously and people don't have that
surplus cash it's actually being pulled
out we're also during also going through
times of crazy geopolitical issues where
there's a war going on in europe which
the us is heavily involved in markets
don't like war people definitely like to
withdraw their assets the ones that
we're seeing when there's chaos we need
some stability some security let's go
into bitcoin let's go because bitcoin is
still a risk on asset right like it's
only 13 years old and so naturally
people are going to withdraw their money
from it like during times of uncertainty
do you feel comfortable holding bitcoin